This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。其中“2”用的是数字。在《回看过去》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我是个重要时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难学艺》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都觉得不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着。并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学艺》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名男同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《被爱困住》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被爱困住》播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, I hope you are ready for a big episode, a very long episode, an incredibly interesting episode. We are talking about the psychology of plastic surgery. We know that there is this huge intersection between plastic surgery and psychology, between plastic surgery and insecurity, social conditioning, social media, self-confidence.
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的巨大变化、重要时刻和转折点，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。很高兴你们能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们一如既往地剖析二十岁的心理学。今天，我希望你们准备好迎接一个大制作、非常长且极其有趣的节目。我们正在讨论整形手术的心理学。我们知道，整形手术和心理学之间，整形手术和不安全感、社会制约、社交媒体、自信之间存在着巨大的交集。
And sometimes it stirs up a lot of debate online and in our own conversations. I've always wanted to do an episode on this, but I am not an expert. So I thought I would bring on somebody who most certainly is somebody who has decades of experience, navigating this industry, navigating the emotions to do with plastic surgery, navigating every single little bit and part of, yeah, of this experience and of this process. So I'm so excited to have him on board for a super interesting conversation. Whatever you believe, I just feel like you can learn so much from how he approaches this, what we talk about, the nooks and crannies that we get into. So without further ado, let's talk about the complex, interesting, incredibly fascinating
有时这会在网络上以及我们自己的对话中引发大量争论。我一直想做一期关于这个话题的节目，但我不是专家。所以我想我应该请一位绝对是专家的嘉宾，一位在这个行业有几十年经验的专家，他经历过与整形手术相关的情感波折，经历过这段经历和这个过程的每一个细枝末节。所以我非常高兴能邀请他来参与这场超级有趣的对话。无论你的信仰如何，我只是觉得你可以从他对待这件事的方式、我们谈论的内容以及我们深入探讨的细节中学到很多东西。所以废话不多说，让我们来聊聊复杂、有趣且极为迷人的
psychology of plastic surgery. Dr. Rati Raban, welcome to the show. Can you introduce yourself to the audience and just tell them a bit about who you are and what you do? Sure. My name's Rodi Raban. I'm a board certified plastic surgeon out of Beverly Hills in California in the United States. I've been a board certified plastic surgeon practicing predominantly, I would say aesthetic surgery for over 20 years in this sort of epicenter of Beverly Hills. And I've done, I kind of uniquely find myself doing all aspects of plastic surgery. Usually the minute you tell someone you do plastic surgery, their next question is, oh, really? Okay, great. What do you specialize in? And I kind of find myself a little bit of a unicorn in that I literally do face, nose, eyelid,
整形手术心理学。拉蒂·拉班博士，欢迎来到节目。你能向听众做个自我介绍，并简单讲讲你是谁、你是做什么的吗？当然。我叫罗迪·拉班。我是美国加州贝弗利山庄的董事会认证整形外科医生。我是一名董事会认证的整形外科医生，主要从事美学手术，可以说在这个贝弗利山庄的中心地带已经超过20年了。而且我发现自己非常独特地包办了整形手术的所有方面。通常一有人听说你做整形手术，他们的下一个问题就是：“哦，真的吗？太好了。你专攻什么？”我发现自己有点像个独角兽，因为我确实在做面部、鼻子、眼睑、
breast, bellies, et cetera, et cetera. So I do the gamut of plastic surgery. This is the question I've always wanted to ask a plastic surgeon, which is, how did you find yourself in this industry slash in this space? Like when you went and did your MD or I don't know what the process is in the US, did you know you wanted to do plastic surgery or did you just kind of like trip and fall into it? That's a great question. The answer is that people go about it in both ways. Some people know early on, I would say most sort of find themselves, uh, trip and fall into it. I always, always wanted to do something in design, fusion with science. You know, I actually wanted to be a mechanical engineer for a period of time and then I wanted
乳房、腹部等等。所以我涉猎整形手术的全套项目。这是我一直想问整形外科医生的一个问题，那就是：你是怎么进入这个行业或这个领域的？比如当你去读医学博士时，或者我不知道在美国的具体流程是怎样的，你是一开始就知道自己想做整形手术，还是某种程度上阴差阳错地走上了这条路？这是个好问题。答案是人们有各种不同的途径。有些人很早就知道了，但我会说大多数人都是阴差阳错、机缘巧合地进入这个领域的。我一直、总是想做一些将设计与科学融合的事情。你知道，我有一段时间实际上想成为一名机械工程师，然后我想
to be an architect. So plastic surgery was a, the minute I decided, I went to college at UCLA, which is down the street from my home. And I went in as a biochemistry major just simply because I liked science and science came pretty naturally to me. But I always knew that I need to do something in the design, aesthetic, creative realm. But I had a very strong liking towards the sciences, mechanical and civil engineering. So when you actually really, really think about it, plastic surgery is that beautiful fusion. And then I always loved entrepreneurship.
成为一名建筑师。所以整形手术是——我决定之后，我去了离我家不远街区加州大学洛杉矶分校（UCLA）上大学。我选修生物化学专业仅仅是因为我喜欢科学，科学对我来说也相当自然。但我一直知道我需要做一些与设计、审美、创意领域相关的事情。但我对科学、机械和土木工程有着非常强烈的喜爱。所以当你真正、真正地去思考时，整形手术就是那种美丽的融合。而且我一直热爱创业。
I love business. I love, you know, VCs, I love Shark Tank. And then when you think about plastic surgery, it is actually the perfect tricycle. It's, you know, business, medicine, and design, all merged into one. And for you to be arguably successful, you need to sort of excel in all three categories. If you imagine one of those wheels being smaller than the others, you're not going to get very far. So it was actually the minute I got to undergrad, I knew pretty quickly that I wanted to do something in the medical space. And the only thing in medicine that allows you this degree of latitude into creative element really is plastic surgery, not orthopedics, not OBGYN, not pediatrics. So it was plastic surgery or bust. That's so interesting that you say it's like almost a creative part of
我热爱商业。我喜欢风险投资，我喜欢《创智赢家》（Shark Tank）。当你想到整形手术时，它其实是一个完美的平衡三轮车。它是商业、医学和设计的完美融合，三者合一。要想取得可以说得过去的成功，你需要在所有这三个类别中都表现出色。如果你想象其中一个车轮比其他车轮小，你就走不了多远。所以其实我一上大学，就很快清楚地知道我想在医疗领域做点什么。医学领域中唯一能让你在创意元素上有如此大自由度的真的是整形手术，而不是骨科，不是妇产科，不是儿科。所以要么是整形手术，要么就一事无成。你提到整形手术几乎是医学中富有创意的一部分，这太有趣了。
medicine. And I feel like when I first hear that, I'm like, wow, that sounds, that's like actually, that sounds strange and then I'm like, well, yeah, you are. You're like sculpting the body and changing it to match someone's vision for how they want to look, which is the fact that they're putting their care in your hands to execute their vision is also pretty amazing. Like, there must be a great deal of trust in that as well for you to have these people come to. Yeah, I mean, I actually take it with great reverence and a certain degree of stress associated with it. you know, I think the sign of a great surgeon is one who has a certain degree of humility and fear. And that fear is, you know, you say people are God-fearing and that, you know, they have
我觉得我第一次听到时，心里想，哇，听起来真——这其实听起来有点奇怪，然后我又想，好吧，确实是的。你就像是在雕塑身体，并对其进行改变，以符合某人对自己外观的愿景，事实上他们把护理托付在你的手中来执行他们的愿景，这也是相当了不起的。就像，这里面一定也有着巨大的信任，才能让这些人来到——是的，我的意思是，我实际上怀着极大的敬畏之心和一定程度的压力来看待这件事。你知道，我认为一个伟大外科医生的标志是那些既有一定的谦逊感又带有某种敬畏心的人。这种敬畏心就是，你知道人们说人要有敬畏神明的心，（G-d-fearing）也就是
respect for something outside of themselves. And so when people come to you and they say, you know, whether it's a young girl or a young gentleman or an older person or what have you, and there's something about themselves that doesn't, isn't congruent with the way they see themselves and they ask you to help them get there, it's a very, um, sizable responsibility. And so I take it as such. So I have always been in awe with what I get to do on a daily basis. I never take it lightly. One more icebreaker question for you. And I don't know if this is, if this is a weird question. And you can not answer it if you don't want to. What was the first surgery that you performed as a plastic surgeon? Do you remember? Of course I do. I remember it vividly.
他们对自身以外的事物保持尊重。所以当人们来到你面前，对你说，无论是年轻女孩、年轻绅士、老年人还是其他什么人，他们身上有些东西与他们看待自己的方式不相吻合，并要求你帮助他们达成目标，这是一项非常重大的责任。所以我也是这样看待它的。因此，对于我每天能够做的事情，我一直感到惊叹。我从来不轻视它。再问你一个破冰问题。我不知道这算不算是一个奇怪的问题。如果你不想回答，也可以不回答。作为一名整形外科医生，你做的第一台手术是什么？你还记得吗？我当然记得。我记得清清楚楚。
So I've been in practice now 20 plus years. And, you know, every pilot, every police officer, every person does, has a first of something, right? The first time of fly plane. And you think to yourself like, okay, but like those other jobs, like, who cares if you mess it up? Who cares if you fuck it up? But with surgery, the first person is, you know, it's going to have to, is the one who is your icebreaker. So the first surgery I did actually was a breast augmentation. A very dear friend of mine who I adore and was at my wedding and is still a very close friend of mine,
所以我的执业生涯已经有20多年了。而且，你知道，每个飞行员、每个警察、每个人都有他们的“第一次”，对吧？第一次开飞机。你会对自己说：“好吧，但是像那些其他工作一样，如果你搞砸了谁在乎呢？如果你把事情弄糟了谁在乎呢？”但对于外科手术来说，第一个病人是，你知道的，必须是——那个帮你破冰的人。所以我做的第一台手术实际上是一个隆胸手术。我的一位非常亲爱的好朋友，我非常崇拜她，她曾出席我的婚礼，现在依然是我非常亲密的朋友，
always had great faith in me. And she sent me one of her friends who had had a few kids. And I ended up doing a breast augmentation on her. And I remember her very, very well because she was so sweet and so bubbly. She had had four children. And yeah, I did my first case was a first breast dog. And it actually went quite well. Yeah.
她一直对我有很大的信任。她把她的一个生过几个孩子的朋友介绍给我。最后我给她做了一个隆胸手术。我把她记得非常非常清楚，因为她太甜美、太活泼了。她生过四个孩子。是的，我的第一个病例是一个隆胸首秀。而且手术其实做得相当不错。是的。
She's still sending me patience. So I think it was a success. Well, that's good. Moving on to like the actual questions around the nitty-gritty of plastic surgery, one thing I feel like we need to get out of the way slash discuss is the difference between plastic surgery and cosmetic procedures or cosmetic surgery. I feel like I think they're kind of different. Am I wrong in that or are they quite similar?
她现在还在给我介绍病人。所以我认为这是一个成功。好了，言归正传，谈谈关于整形手术核心细节的实际问题，我觉得我们需要先厘清并讨论的一个问题是，整形手术（plastic surgery）和美容微调（cosmetic procedures）或美容手术（cosmetic surgery）之间的区别。我觉得它们似乎有所不同。我的看法错了吗，还是它们其实挺相似的？
So I think you ask a very good question. If the goal of today's episode is to educate and elevate people's understanding, then you've got to understand the alphabet soup. You've got to understand the vocabulary. You've got to understand the glossary of plastic surgery. And so unlike all other fields, plastic surgery is very confusing. And that's not by accident. Because ultimately, a lot of it is driven by marketing. Marketing. You don't get confused when you have an arrhythmia and your heart is not functioning correct, you go to a cardiologist. There's no confusion on that.
所以我觉得你问了一个非常好的问题。如果今天这期节目的目标是教育大众并提升公众的理解，那么你必须了解这些让人头晕目干的缩写。你必须了解词汇。你必须了解整形手术的术语表。所以不像其他所有领域，整形手术非常令人混淆。这绝非偶然。因为归根结底，很大程度上是由市场营销驱动的。营销。当你心律失常且心脏功能不正常时，你去看心脏病专家，这不会让人感到困惑。这绝对没有任何混淆。
When you have a ovarian cyst, you go to your OBGYN, your gyne, your gynecologist, you're obstetrician. There's no confusion in that. But in the area of cosmetics, my God, there are thousands of different providers with all kinds of names and things like that. So the way it works is as follows. When you go, at least in the United States, when you go to medical, school, you are all equal. And then you have to select a specialty. You say, okay, when I'm done with my four years of med school, I'm going to be a, again, orthopedist, neurologist, psychiatrists, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, and one of those is a plastic surgeon. There is no cosmetic surgery residency. There is no, it's just
当你患有卵巢囊肿时，你会去看妇产科医生。这没有任何混淆。但在美容领域，天哪，有成千上万不同的提供商，有着各种各样的名字等等。它是这样运作的。当你去，至少在美国，当你去读医科，学校里，你们所有人都是平等的。然后你必须选择一个专业。你说，好吧，当我完成四年的医学院学习后，我要成为一名，再次声明，骨科医生、神经科医生、精神科医生等等等等，其中之一就是整形外科医生。并没有什么美容外科住院医师项目。并没有，它只是
plastic surgery. There are dermatologists and there are ear, nose and throat. doctors, but cosmetic surgery is not a residency. You then go into being a plastic surgeon, and in your training, which is quite diverse, one of the things that you learn is aesthetics, beauty, cosmetics. So you'll learn burn surgery. You'll learn reconstructive surgery with microsurgery. You'll learn hand surgery, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And one of them is beauty or aesthetics or cosmetic surgery. Then if when you graduate, you decide, you know what, I really like cosmetic. surgery. I really want to specialize in this in my career. Then you will take additional training, but you will be a board certified plastic surgeon who specializes in aesthetic surgery,
整形外科。有皮肤科医生，也有耳鼻喉科医生，但美容外科不是一个住院医师培训项目。然后你成为一名整形外科医生，在你的培训过程中——这是相当多样化的——你学到的其中一件事就是美学、美、美容。所以你会学习烧伤手术。你会通过显微外科学习重建手术。你会学习手外科等等等等。其中之一就是美、美学或美容手术。然后如果你毕业后决定，你知道吗，我真的很喜欢美容外科。我真的想在我的职业生涯中专攻这个领域。那么你将接受额外的培训，但你将是一名专攻美学手术的董事会认证整形外科医生，
which is what I do. Then comes, you know, years go by. And then the field of medicine, naturally, like all other businesses, is driven by money. Non-cosmetic things like my gallbladder, my hernia, becomes poorer and poorer. So what that does is it drives people who are not trained, in aesthetic surgery to then change directions mid mid game and say you know what i can do this how hard could this be and then they then start to take any any any variety of lessons whether that be watching a friend going to courses whatever they want and then overnight they can deem themselves as cosmetic surgeons i know that's hard to imagine i know it's really Like, no, come on.
这也是我所做的。然后，随着时间的推移，医学领域自然地像所有其他商业一样，是由金钱驱动的。非美容的事情，比如我的胆囊、我的疝气，变得越来越不赚钱。因此，这导致那些没有接受过美学手术培训的人在中途改变方向，说，你知道吗，我能做到这一点，这能有多难？然后他们开始采取任何各种各样的学习方式，无论是看朋友、去上课、他们想上的任何课程，然后一夜之间他们就可以自称为美容外科医生。我知道这很难想象，我知道这真的很——
And so if you go look at cosmetic surgeons and you start to say, okay, well, where, what is your actual training in? You will find out that they were general surgeons. They were OBGYNs. They were radiologists. They were ER physicians. And at some point in their career, they decided, I don't want to do a shit anymore. And then they get whatever degree of training, which is not very regulated. And then they call themselves cosmetic surgeons.
不，拜托。所以如果你去看看那些美容外科医生，开始追问，好吧，那么，你实际接受的培训是什么？你会发现他们曾经是普外科医生。他们曾经是妇产科医生。他们曾经是放射科医生。他们曾经是急诊室医生。在他们职业生涯的某个阶段，他们决定，我不想再处理那些破事了。然后他们获得了某种程度的培训，而这并没有受到很好的监管。然后他们就自称为美容外科医生。
So the answer is your listeners need to. to sadly do their home. Yeah. And I agree with that entirely. And it's so interesting to hear behind the scenes of like the labels and like you said, the alphabet soup. I also just think like if you're going to permanently change the way you look and undergo surgery, it's not something necessarily to skimp on or to cut corners with. So you like bring up a very interesting point, which is like think this through and there's multiple sides to think through. Before I go, further in that kind of direction. You know, we're talking about plastic surgery,
所以答案是，你们的听众需要悲哀地做好他们的功课。是的，我完全同意这一点。听到这些幕后关于标签以及你所说的各种繁杂缩写，真的非常有趣。我也只是觉得，如果你要永久改变你的外表并接受手术，这不一定是应该偷工减料或走捷径的事情。所以你提出了一个非常有趣的点，那就是：仔细考虑这一点，而且有多个方面需要思考。在我向那个方向深入探讨之前。你知道，我们在谈论整形手术，
specifically in our 20s, really. I just have to ask, how many people are getting plastic surgery in their 20s? What is the most popular age group that you see that gets worked on? So that's very interesting. So it turns out that every decade has its more common procedures. I will say more than ever before
特别是在我们二十岁的时候。我不得不问，有多少人在二十多岁时做整形手术？你看到做过手术的最受欢迎的年龄段是哪个？这非常有趣。事实证明，每个十年都有其更常见的项目。我想说，比以往任何时候都多的是，
younger and younger patients are coming in to get surgery. Why is that? Social media. The end. We've always had young people having surgery. My sister, who's almost 60, had her nose done 30-some-odd years ago. My mom, who's 85, had her nose done 60 years ago. So it wasn't crazy to go to nose job.
越来越年轻的患者走进诊所接受手术。为什么会这样？社交媒体。就这么简单。我们一直都有年轻人做手术。我姐姐快60岁了，她在30多年前做过鼻子。我妈妈85岁，她在60年前做过鼻子。所以去做鼻整形并不是什么疯狂的事。
But this idea of Bella Hadid cat eyes, mini facelifts, lip-lifts. I mean, there's BBL's lipop, fat transfer, rib remodeling. There's some crazy things that are getting done and they're getting done younger and younger. The only reason that is occurring is social media. That being said, you know, there's things that have happened at different ages in our life. So let's start with 20s. What are the things that people come in commonly for their 20s that are within reason? And what are some of the bad things that I think are a little overboard?
但这股贝拉·哈迪德（Bella Hadid）式的猫眼、微型拉皮、唇部提升。我的意思是，有巴西提臀术（BBL）、吸脂、脂肪移植、肋骨重塑。有些非常疯狂的事情正在被完成，而且做得越来越年轻。发生这种情况的唯一原因就是社交媒体。话虽如此，你知道，在我们生命的不同阶段，会有不同的事情发生。所以让我们从20多岁开始。在20多岁时，人们通常会做哪些在情理之中的手术？以及我认为有些稍微过火的糟糕手术是什么？
If you're 20-year-old young lady and your breasts never really fully developed and you find that while you love your body and you think everything about yourself is amazing, you work out and everything, but you just simply never develop much breast tissue, then getting a breast augmentation is not an unreasonable concept. And that happens often in your 20s. If you were born and you were unlucky and your nose just was crazy out of balance with your face and you and you and. inherited his big nose and otherwise we're a beautiful young lady. It doesn't seem crazy to alter your nose and get a rhinoclasty. That happens in your 20s. If you were born with a very weak chin, just because genetically, orthognatically, you've never developed and you have a massive underbite, it's not crazy to get a small chin implant or an enhancement
如果你是一个20岁的年轻女性，你的胸部从未真正完全发育，你发现虽然你热爱自己的身材，认为自己的一切都很棒，你经常锻炼等等，但你就是没有发育出太多的乳房组织，那么做个隆胸并不是一个不合理的观念。这在二十多岁时经常发生。如果你生来就不走运，你的鼻子与你的面部极度不协调，你遗传了大鼻子，除此之外你是个漂亮的年轻女性。改变你的鼻子并做个鼻整形术似乎并不疯狂。这发生在二十多岁时。如果你生来下巴就很弱，仅仅因为遗传学或正颌学原因，你从未发育好并且有严重的地包天，弄个小下巴假体来增强下巴以创造和谐与平衡并不疯狂。这发生在二十多岁时。相反地，现在有人打电话来询问眉上提术。
of your chin to create harmony imbalance. That happens in your 20s. Conversely, now we're getting people calling about brow lifts. but you're 20 lip lips face lips neck lips rib remodeling those are some really extreme surgeries that are not were never really designed or really indicated for young adults so i think the question you're going to lead to eventually is where is the line right and the answer is who knows and that line is drawn by both surgeon and patient but i i don't know if that answers your question but those are often the surgeries that are getting done.
但你才20岁，有唇部提升、面部提升、颈部提升、肋骨重塑，这些是一些真正极端的 ไม่适合、也从未真正为年轻人设计或适应的手术。所以我认为你最终会提出的问题是，底线在哪里？答案是，谁知道呢。这条底线是由外科医生和患者共同划定的。我不知道这是否回答了你的问题，但这些通常是正在做的手术。
I think it, no, it totally does. And I feel like this is an even broader discussion of like, what is the point where you get something done because it is a genuine deep insecurity for you? And then what is the point you get something done where there is genuinely nothing wrong and genuinely nothing that a surgery could actually do? Like you're saying a brow lift for someone who is, you know,
我觉得，不，完全回答了。我觉得这是一个更广泛的讨论，比如：你在什么情况下做某项手术是因为它确实是你内心深处的极度不安全感？又在什么情况下你做某手术时，其实根本没有问题，而且没有任何手术真正能解决问题？就像你说的，给一个22或23岁的人做提眉术。我觉得这就是社交媒体极大地左右人们想法的切入点。你觉得FaceTune或Instagram畸形恐惧症、体象障碍是如何改变人们对正常美的认知的？正如你提到的一些真正极端的项目。你是否也看到年轻人为了比实际需要更多的手术而来到诊所？
22 or 23. And I feel like that's where the entrance of social media has probably greatly, greatly swayed people. How have you seen FaceTune or Instagram dysmorphia, dysphoria, change how people perceive normal beauty? Like you mentioned some of those really extreme procedures. Are you also seeing younger people coming in for perhaps more surgeries than they need? like repeat people coming in and changing back to a certain way or, you know,
比如反复有人来做手术，在几年内多次重新调整某个特定的样子，或者，
redoing their nose or redoing their eyes or redoing their cheeks multiple times in the span of years. I'm curious to see how you've seen the impact of this even further. Okay. So we got to start with the psychology of beauty. Plain and simple. This is well before any social media. This goes back to Cleopatra. This goes back to the Amazon. You know, you go to the Amazon right now with a bunch, in a tribe where no one's seen any human beings outside of the Amazon. And you're going to know who the queen of the tribe is. She's the one with the most beautiful neck and the, you know, beauty is not a concept of modern times. Beauty is something that we know. There's tons of
多次重做鼻子、重做眼睛或重做脸颊？我很想看看你如何看待这种影响的进一步加深。好吧。我们必须从审美的心理学开始。简单明了。这远在任何社交媒体出现之前就已经存在了。这可以追溯到克利奥帕特拉。这可以追溯到亚马逊雨林。你知道，你现在去亚马逊雨林的一个部落，那里的所有人都没有见过亚马逊以外的人类。你一眼就能认出谁是部落的女王。她拥有最漂亮的脖子，还有，你知道的，美并非现代概念。美是我们所熟知的东西。有大量
studies that show that like monkeys will go to the more more attractive puppet than the other than the other puppet. So there is an inherent built in us to desire to, you know, it comes from mating, Right. Animals in the wild will go to the more attractive bird or the more attractive flower. So there is that. And then there is this turbocharged version, this version where you have this sort of innate being in our beings as people, this desire to look good or feel good or present our best. And then you pour gasoline on it. And I think that's essentially what social media has done. In modern society, we've had billboards. We have actors and actresses. We had magazines. We had celebrities. We had models. This has existed for over 200 years, right? And, you know, oh, I think Merlin-Roe is so beautiful.
研究表明，比如猴子会走向更有吸引力的木偶而不是另一个木偶。所以我们内心里有一种与生俱来的欲望去——这源于繁衍，对吧。野外的动物会走向更有吸引力的鸟类或更吸引人的花朵。所以这是存在的。然后还有这种被涡轮增压的版本，这种版本存在于我们作为人类的本能中，即追求好看、感觉良好或展现最好自己的欲望。然后你往上面浇汽油。我认为这基本上就是社交媒体所做的事情。在现代社会中，我们有广告牌。我们有男演员和女演员。我们有杂志。我们有名人。我们有模特。这种情况已经存在200多年了，对吧？而且，你知道，“噢，我觉得玛丽莲·梦露太美了。”
Oh, my God, look at Grace Kelly. And it always sort of people admired and wanted to sort of emulate some of these people. But it was still manageable because those people were those people. Like, oh, I really want to go to this place I see in this postcard. It's a real place. Right? You can actually go there. And then we get into the modern world where manipulation,
“噢，天哪，看格蕾丝·凯利。”人们总是钦佩并希望效仿其中的一些人。但这依然是可控的，因为那些人毕竟是那些人。就像，“噢，我真的很想去我在明信片上看到的这个地方。这是一个真实的地方。”对吧？你真的可以去那里。然后我们进入了现代世界，
alteration, fabrication, whether it's AI, FaceTune, filters, angles, and morph. And then reality changes. And because inherently we are vulnerable, right, we're all vulnerable, 16, 17, 18, even grown-ass adults are immature and have insecurities, then you, massively at a very high level, you start bombarding people with images, right? Social media. You'd see a billboard while driving.
这里充斥着操纵、篡改、伪造，无论是人工智能、FaceTune、滤镜、角度还是变形。然后现实就改变了。正因为我们生来脆弱，对吧，我们都很脆弱，16、17、18岁，甚至成年人都很不成熟且充满不安全感，然后你以极高的强度、海量的信息开始轰炸人们，对吧？社交媒体。你开车时会看到广告牌。
Let's say you drive on Sunset Boulevard. You'd see 25 billboards over five miles. You now see 25 images within five seconds. Yeah. And these images are bombarding you. Secondly, they are not real. So you're looking at a destination. Like, oh, my God, look how.
假设你开在日落大道上。你在五英里内会看到25个广告牌。你现在能在五秒钟内看到25张图片。是的。这些图片正在狂轰滥炸你。其次，它们不是真实的。所以你在看一个目的地。就像，“噢，天哪，看这些树和水有多美。”根本没有这个地方。这个岛根本不存在。它不是一个真实的岛屿。她看起来根本不是那个样子的。不，看看克里斯·詹娜（Chris Jenner）。看看克里斯·詹娜通过她的拉皮手术引发的轰动，对吧？
beautiful, these trees and the water. There is no place. This island doesn't exist. It's not a real island. She doesn't look that way. No, look at Chris Jenner. Look at the excitement that Chris Jenner generated with her facelit, right? There must be one trillion views or comments.
一定有一万亿的浏览量或评论。好吧，是的，她看起来不错。但她看起来那么好的原因在于，过去六个月里她发布的每一张图片都经过了FaceTune处理。现在由于她的图片，她无法一直维持那种状态，人们开始注意到她看起来并不像前几个月那样光彩照人、惊艳动人了，因为她把一切都P过图了。所以人们以为，等等，你有无瑕的皮肤。不，她没有无瑕的皮肤。她快70岁了。
Well, yes, she looks good. But the reason she looks so good is she's face-tuned every image that's come out over the last six months. And now that her images, she cannot stay up on it, people are noticing that she doesn't look as glossy and amazing as she did the first couple of months because she's face-tuned everything. So people are thinking that, wait, you have flawless skin. No, she doesn't have flawless skin. She's almost 70.
她做了一个很好的拉皮手术。她看起来很惊艳，但她并没有无瑕的皮肤。所以我想表达的是，这里存在一种平衡：什么是合理的、有机的、属于人类一部分的东西。然后是你倒在这个闷烧的自我部分上的汽油，然后它就失控了。然后发生的事情是，我们90%的人都容易受到影响。所以当你还不成熟、很脆弱，只有13、12、8、9、16或17岁，
She has a good facelift. She looks amazing, but she doesn't have flawless skin. So what I'm getting at is there's this balance between what is reasonable and what is organic and what is part of humanity. And then there's this gasoline that you poured on this smoldering part of us. And then it's gotten out of control. And then what happens is 90% of us are subject to being impacted. And so when you are immature and you're vulnerable and you're 13 or 12 or 8 or 9 or 16 or 17
而且几乎每个人都会经历一段小尴尬期，他们的声音在变。他们在不该长毛的地方长毛。管他呢。你看着这些图片，你产生了FOMO（错失恐惧症）以及诸如此类的感觉，比如：“噢，天哪，我离那种状态太远了。天哪，我怎么这么丑？”而你距离一个根本不存在的地方相去甚远。
and almost every human being goes through a little awkward time, their voice is changing. They're growing hair in places they shouldn't be growing. Whatever. You look at these images and you get phomo and all this sort of sense of like, oh, wow, I'm so far from that. my God, how ugly am I? And you're so far from a place that doesn't exist.
有一个令人惊叹的说法是：它创造了什么？悲伤、抑郁、焦虑。有一个非常棒的说法。它说，你的快乐取决于你所处的位置和你认为你应该达到的位置之间的差距。我要重复一遍。你的快乐取决于你所处的位置和你认为你应该达到的位置。
And there's an amazing saying is, so it creates what? Sadness, depression, anxiety. And there's a very great saying. It says that your happiness is based on the delta between where you are and where you think you ought to be. I'm going to repeat that. Your happiness is based on where you are and where you think you ought to be.
所以你在这里。我赚X钱，我长这样，我，这是我的妻子。而你认为你应该达到的位置，是你认为自己可能达到的相对位置。你认为自己可能达到的位置应该是：拥有无瑕的皮肤、极棒的男友、住在船上、开着劳斯莱斯等等、苗条的身材、大屁股、小细腰，那么你距离那个目标就十万八千里了，这就会导致感到悲伤、抑郁、焦虑。然后你就会去做什么？去追逐它。这就是我们今天的处境。
So you are here. I make X, I look like this, I, this is my wife. And where you think you ought to be is the relativiveness of where you think you could be. And where you think you could be should be flawless skin with an amazing boyfriend, living on a boat, driving a Rose Royce, blah, blah, blah, skinny body, big butt, small waist, then you are far, far away from that, which then leads to feeling sad, depressed, anxious. And then what you do is you chase it. And that's where we are today.
所以我认为，从8、9岁一直到成年人，这些没有安全感的人群中所存在的精神不满和悲伤是如此巨大。我真的、真的认为社交媒体难辞其咎。不是整形手术的错。不是对美的追求的错。而是你在创造这些永远不会存在的平行宇宙的事实。这就好象色情片一样。它不是真的。所以无论如何。
And so I think that the amount of mental dissatisfaction and sadness amongst insecure people ranging from 8,9, all the way up to grown-ass adults is so massive. And I really, really think social media is to blame. It's not plastic surgery. It's not the chase to be beauty. It's the fact that you're creating these alternative universes that will never exist. It's like porn. It's not real. So anyways.
这就是问题所在。是的。不，我完全同意你的看法。作为一个在自己的生活中亲眼目睹过这种情况发生的人，我也深有同感，当时我曾想：“哇，这个人真是太棒了。如果我有那样的一切，难道所有其他事情不都会改变吗？”我们知道，从心理学上讲，而且我相信你也清楚，显然，随着快乐适应（hedonic adaptation），你可以去做手术。
That's the problem. Yeah. No, I totally agree with you. And I agree with you as someone who has seen that happen to me in my own life, where I've been like, wow, this person is just so amazing. If I had that, wouldn't all these other things change? And we know, like, psychologically, and I'm sure you know this as well, obviously, like, with hedonic adaptation, you could have surgery.
它可能会改变你的生活。通常情况下，你实际上会回到基准的幸福水平。这正是你刚才所说的，关于克里斯·詹娜做了这个手术，我确信对她而言，她当时想的是，这将是彻底消除所有不安全感的一招，然而她仍然在使用FaceTune，然而可能仍然有她不喜欢的事情。我们每个人内心都有一个批判者，而社交媒体
It might change your life. Normally, you are actually going to return to a baseline level of happiness. it's exactly what you were saying about, you know, Chris Jenna got this surgery and I'm sure for her she was thinking, this will be the one that eliminates all insecurity, and yet she's still face tunes, and yet there's probably still things she doesn't like. There's like an inner critic in all of us that social media
以及不切实际的美丽标准确实在推波助澜。这就让我引出了这次采访中最具争议的问题之一。我们要稍事休息，等我们回来后，我将把这个问题抛给你。所以请继续关注我们。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开那些统治健康行业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
and the unrealisticness of beauty is really kind of promoting. This kind of brings me to, I think probably one of the more, controversial questions of this interview. We're going to take a short break and then when we return, I'm going to pose it to you. So stay with us. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that
我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力导致的。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在i-Hart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。其中“2%”用的是数字。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）
dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, you're more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross
在VMAs上双击（亲吻）小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一集里，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
包括最近一集有马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）做客，大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因（crack）。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊关于可卡因的事，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了，所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上，所以。谢谢你把那句话说完。是的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学艺》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·加恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你是个好人，是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro.
绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地去成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·加恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学艺》中，我们一起畅谈关于疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《艰难学艺》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregalespian）和迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranini）。
I doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Maranini.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《被爱困住》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《被爱困住》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金规则。规则一，永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的闺蜜。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜们》的这个新季节里……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，不。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝。这是我想问的问题。一个人能否真正做到悦纳自我（body positive），却依然想要改变自己的外表？
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. This is the question I want to ask. Can someone be truly body positive and still want to change how they look?
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。听听女朋友们的说法。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你收听播客的任何地方。这是我想问的问题。一个人真的可以完全做到身体自信，却仍然想要改变自己的外表吗？
Is there, I guess, something that surgery can never fix within somebody? So the answer is, let me get, let me make sure I understand the question. Can somebody truly love themselves, as we say today, be body positive, I think I'm amazing, and still find benefit from a surgery? Is that what the question is? I think still find benefit from a surgery or still find themselves thinking about a surgery. Does thinking about surgery, no, go ahead. So the answer is absolutely yes.
我想，有没有什么是手术永远无法为一个人修复的？所以答案是，让我理清一下，确保我理解了这个问题。一个人是否能真正地爱自己，就像我们今天所说的，保持身体积极（body positive），觉得自己棒极了，但同时依然能从手术中获益？这就是问题所在吗？我想是依然能从手术中获益，或者依然发现自己在考虑手术。考虑手术，不，你请说。所以答案是绝对可以的。
So that would equate the ideal. patient. The ideal patient is one who comes to you, who is otherwise very happy in their life. They have stability in their interpersonal relationships. They come in with a very finite issue, one that can easily be agreed upon. And as a result, the correction or the eradication of that one very specific issue can for sure, and I have now witnessed it for 20 plus years, dramatically change, enhance, and improve the quality of life of that person. So let me give you such examples. So you see a young lady and they come into your office. I refer to my four nieces and they are boss ladies. One's in law school. One's a venture capitalist. They played sports.
这就可以等同于理想的患者。理想的患者是这样一种人：他们来到你面前，在其他方面生活中非常幸福。他们的人际关系非常稳定。他们带着非常具体的问题来，一个容易达成一致的问题。因此，对这一个非常特定问题的矫正或消除，绝对可以——而且我见证了20多年——极大地改变、提升和改善那个人的生活质量。所以让我给你举几个这样的例子。你会看到一个年轻女士，她们走进你的诊所。我以我的四个侄女为例，她们都是职场女强人。一个在读法学院。一个风投家。她们打过运动。
Their soccer. One was valedictorian. By all intents of purposes, kicking out. ass, boyfriends, everything, love their moms, just a great, like, great, great girls. Yet because of genetics, while they are beautiful and have great skin and nice teeth and everything, with all fairness, all four of my niece had bad noses. And so these four nieces of mine, on their own, really disliked their noses. Every other aspect of their lives were kick ass on 90th percent of whatever. So we sat down individually, and I mentioned them because there's so four different young ladies of all different ranges. And we identified the issues.
她们踢足球。一个是毕业典礼致辞学生（valedictorian）。无论从什么意图和目的来看，她们都非常出色，有男朋友，什么都有，爱她们的妈妈，就是很棒、很棒、很棒的女孩。然而由于基因原因，虽然她们很漂亮，皮肤很好，牙齿也很好，说句公道话，我的四个侄女都有不好看的鼻子。所以这四个侄女凭她们自己，真的很不喜欢她们的鼻子。她们生活的方方面面在百分之九十的领域都极其出色。所以我们单独坐下来聊了聊，我提到她们是因为这里有四个不同年龄段、各不相同的年轻女孩。我们指出了问题。
We had discussions. And we said, okay, if we alter your nose and create a better harmony, not perfection, not the nose on Angelina Jolie or let me see what Margot, a better looking nose on you, would this create a little bit of better appearance and hence make you happier? And the answer is all four of them, all four of their noses were done at different times in their lives, different ages. All four of their noses still have flaws, because I'm a critic and I know. And all four of them are over the moon about their noses. And then hence moved on and never looked back. So nothing about the way they love themselves has holistically changed.
我们进行了讨论。然后我们说，好吧，如果我们改变你的鼻子，创造出更好的和谐感，不是完美，不是安吉丽娜·朱莉那样的鼻子，或者让我看看玛格特（Margot）什么的，在你脸上弄一个更好看的鼻子，这会不会带来一点更好的外表，从而让你更开心呢？答案是，她们四个人的鼻子都在她们生命的不用阶段、不同年龄做过手术。她们四个人的鼻子依然有瑕疵，因为我是个评论家，我很懂。而且她们四个对自己的鼻子都兴奋得不得了。然后就继续前行，再也没有回头。所以她们爱自己的方式在整体上没有任何改变。
But that one entity about themselves is significantly improved, which then adds to their overall confidence. Could they have lived life without it? Sure. Had they not had the means, would it have drastically changed their lives? No. But the fact that they were lucky enough to be able to afford it, have a surgeon who executed it, and it ended up being positive, has unarguably changed a trajectory of their life.
但她们身上那一个实体得到了显著改善，这进而增加了她们的整体自信。她们没有它能过生活吗？当然可以。如果她们没有这个经济条件，这会彻底改变她们的生活吗？不会。但她们足够幸运能够承担得起费用，找到一位执行得当的外科医生，而且结果最终是积极的，这无可辩驳地改变了她们的生活轨迹。
And I can tell of you that 95% of my patients, their lives have been massively improved by whatever surgery they did, where there was a mommy makeover after having multiple kids. And I can give you the stories behind these people. So if you've had three kids, you kick ass, you love. your husband your husband loves you your children are healthy you do yoga you go fix your body and now your insides match your outsides no amount of diet and exercise would have changed it right so these are such examples that connect with stories we are very good at isolating oh you should just love yourself your husband should love you this is all nonsense so the answer your question is when a patient is
我可以告诉你，我95%的患者，无论他们做了什么手术，生活都得到了巨大的改善，无论是在生了多个孩子之后的辣妈改造手术（mommy makeover）。我可以讲讲这些人背后的故事。所以如果你生了三个孩子，你很棒，你爱你的丈夫，你丈夫爱你，你的孩子们很健康，你练瑜伽，你去修饰你的身材，现在你的内在与你的外貌相匹配了，再多的节食和运动也无法改变这一点，对吧？所以这些都是与故事相连的例子。我们非常擅长孤立地说，哦，你应该只爱你自己，你丈夫应该爱你，这全都是无稽之谈。所以你问题的答案是，当一个患者是
a good patient a well qualified patient and has a stability around themselves and we're fixing a very finite issue, then yes, I do think they can be body positive and yet still have a dramatic improvement in their life. I find that interesting because I definitely see the point. But with your nieces, like what made them bad, what made them bad noses or like what made the body of the, of the woman who's given birth as a bad body? Like, you mentioned that they, these women were already in the 90th percentile and this woman already had everything. she wanted, what do you think it was about changing this bad part of them or this, I guess, you know, part of them they didn't like that that meant something to them?
一个好患者、一个完全合资格的患者，并且自身周围有一定的稳定性，我们在修复一个非常具体的问题时，那么是的，我确实认为他们既能保持身体积极（body positive），又能让生活发生戏剧性的改善。我觉得这很有趣，因为我完全理解这个观点。但对于你的侄女们，比如是什么让她们的鼻子变得不好，是什么让她们的鼻子成了不好的鼻子，或者什么让那个生育过的女性的身体成了不好的身体？就像你提到的，这些女性已经处于第90百分位数，而这个女性已经拥有了她想要的一切，你认为她们改变这部分不好的自己，或者我猜，你知道，她们不喜欢的那部分自己，对她们来说意味着什么？
Do you know what I mean? So the first question is, yeah. Yeah, yeah, I understand. The first question is defining bad. Bad is a relative term. Yeah, exactly. Like tall is a relative term. Good is a relative term.
你知道我的意思吗？所以第一个问题是，是的。对，对，我明白。第一个问题是定义“不好”。不好是一个相对的概念。是的， exatamente（没错）。就像高是一个相对的概念。好是一个相对的概念。
I use the word in a very simple fashion, but it's, it's much more complicated in that. First of all, I'm not the one that tells them it's bad. So let's be very, very clear. These people come to me. I don't they don't come to me and say hey dr bond how you doing great so what do you think of me i go well you look pretty good but your nose is bad that's not how this goes this is a person who has been dwelling on this subject matter for years seeks out help comes to the office and I say how can I help you and they say well I'm not so happy about my nose what is it about your nose that
我以非常简单的方式使用这个词，但它其实要复杂得多。首先，并不是我告诉她们这不好。所以我们要非常、非常清楚这一点。这些人来找我。我不是……她们不会来找我，然后说，嘿，邦德医生，你好吗？太棒了。那么你觉得我怎么样？我说，嗯，你看起来挺好的，但你的鼻子不好。事情不是这样的。这是一个纠结这个主题多年的人，寻求帮助，来到办公室，我说我能帮你什么？他们说，嗯，我对自己的鼻子不太满意。关于你的鼻子，有什么是
you dislike well I don't like this huge hump I don't like that it's droopy I don't like that my tip is massively bulbous, and that doesn't make it bad. That makes it bad to them. There is no such thing as bad. If that girl or that guy loved those features, then it would be good to them. So when I say bad or good, it's relative to the way they perceive themselves as to either what they would like and or what they used to be. So then people who like to,
你不喜欢的？嗯，我不喜欢这个巨大的驼峰，我不喜欢它下垂，我不喜欢我的鼻尖非常肥大，这并不意味着它不好。这只是对她们来说不好。根本没有所谓的“不好”。如果那个女孩或那个男孩喜欢那些特征，那么对他们来说它就是好的。所以当我说不好或好时，它是相对于她们对自己的感知而言的，即她们想要的和/或者她们以前的样子。所以那些喜欢，
people who like to sort of be naysayers like to be like, well, what, what's wrong with it? Who says that a hump is bad? And they like to sort of play that game. Then I ask you, why did you put on lipstick this morning? Are you wearing mascara? Have you done your nails? Do you cut your short, trim your split ends?
那些喜欢唱反调的人喜欢说，嗯，它有什么问题？谁说有驼峰就不好？他们喜欢玩那种游戏。那么我问你，你今天早上为什么要涂口红？你涂睫毛膏了吗？你做美甲了吗？你剪短头发、修剪分叉了吗？
Do you wear perfume? Do you have jewelry? Well, why do you any of those things? What's wrong with you without perfume? Why are you shaving? under your arms. So if we want to play that game, everyone will fail because it's not about the actual absolute, meaning this is okay and that's not, because all that is is a line in the sand. Who are you to tell me that I'm allowed to put on mascara, but when I get a tattoo, I've gone too far? Who are you to
你喷香水了吗？你有戴首饰吗？嗯，你为什么要做这些事情？不喷香水你有什么毛病？你为什么要刮腋下的毛？所以如果我们想玩那种游戏，每个人都会失败，因为这与实际的绝对值无关，意思是这个可以那个不可以，因为所有这些都只是沙滩上的一条线。你算老几，凭什么告诉我我可以涂睫毛膏，但当我纹身时，我就走得太远了？你算老几，凭
tell me that I'm allowed to put Botox, but if I get a nose job, it's too far. No one can say that. It's about relativism. And relativism is a dangerous area. So because no one can make that definition, it's a slippery slope because the person who has had 47 surgeries can now reverse the argument and be like, so what? Who said 47 is bad? Why is it only two? But we're talking about mentally stable, healthy individuals who look at themselves and feel,
什么告诉我可以使用肉毒杆菌（Botox），但如果我去做隆鼻手术，就太过了？没有人能这么说。这关乎相对主义。而相对主义是一个危险的领域。因为没有人能下这个定义，这是一个滑坡谬误，因为那个做了47次手术的人现在可以反驳说，那又怎样？谁说47次是多的？为什么只能是两次？但我们谈论的是精神稳定、健康、看着自己并觉得
you know what? I don't really love my saggy breasts. And to them, it's bad. And then there's people to them, it's great. And what we have to do as a society is make sure that we don't get too far off the spectrum. And we were doing okay because, you know, at the end of the day, we had realistic images of what could be. But I think the dangerous area, the dangerous waters we're in now is that things are so accessible. You can go to Turkey.
你知道吗？我真的不太喜欢我下垂的胸部。对他们来说，这就是不好的。然后还有人觉得，这太棒了。我们作为社会必须做的事情，是确保我们没有偏离光谱太远。我们原本做得还可以，因为，你知道，归根结底，我们对可能的事情有着现实的图像。但我认为我们现在所处的危险领域、危险水域是，事情太容易获得了。你可以去土耳其。
You can go to downtown. You can go to Miami. Things have become relatively affordable, even though everybody bitches is. expensive. I mean, you could literally go and get a boob job for nothing. And images are endless. So this is a cocktail or a recipe for a very bad outcome. Does that answer your question as to what defines the person as a bad nose or what my nieces felt was a bad nose? Yeah, it does. And I think it's like a very, like you said, it's incredibly complicated. And I think I think the line some people would draw is that there's a difference between mascara and permanently,
你可以去市中心。你可以去迈阿密。事情变得相对负担得起，尽管每个人都在抱怨很贵。我的意思是，你简直可以去花极少的钱做个隆胸手术。而影像又是无休止的。所以这是通往非常糟糕结果的鸡尾酒或配方。这是否回答了你关于如何定义这个人的鼻子不好，或者我侄女们觉得什么是糟糕的鼻子的提问？是的，回答了。而且我认为这就像，就像你说的，这极其复杂。而且我认为有些人会划定的界限是，睫毛膏和永久性地
altering how you look, like you can take the mascara off. You can't take the nose drop off. What do you tell people with tattoos? No, I know. I would have seen the same thing where it's like I mean tattoo, 85% of young adults. Not really. No, that's a lie. Those are what people tell themselves. But tattoos are essentially permanent. Even if you remove it, you have the scar of it. And the reality is that, again, I agree with you. It's all a sense of relativism. And I think it's great to play devil's advocate because we need to make sure that we find center ground. Center ground is that we're not far left, we're not far right, whether that's in politics, whether that's in religion and whether that's in plastic surgical philosophy.
改变你的外表之间是有区别的，比如你可以把睫毛膏卸掉。你没法把隆鼻手术“卸”掉。你对有纹身的人说什么？不，我知道。我看到过同样的情况，就是说，纹身，85%的年轻人都有。真的吗？不，那是谎言。那是人们对自己说的话。但纹身本质上是永久性的。即使你把它去掉了，你也会留下疤痕。现实情况是，再次说明，我同意你的观点。这一切都是一种相对主义感。我认为扮演恶魔的代言人（唱反调）很好，因为我们需要确保我们找到中间立场。中间立场就是我们不极左，我们不极右，无论是政治上、宗教上，还是在整形外科的哲学上。
So I do agree that each person will find that center area and draw that line. And yes, for someone, mascara is reversible, yet a tattoo is not. For some people, that too is not really reversible because I can cover it. So there's all these versions of the way we sell it to ourselves. I think the key is, and it has been for me, because ultimately I'm the gatekeeper, right? I'm the one that is the church. I'm the one that will facilitate this alteration in you. So I take that responsibility quite heavily.
所以我确实同意每个人都会找到那个中心区域并划定那条线。是的，对某些人来说，睫毛膏是可逆的，而纹身不是。对某些人来说，纹身也不是真的不可逆，因为我可以遮盖它。所以我们对自己兜售这些说辞有各种版本。我认为关键在于，对我来说一直如此，因为归根结底我是守门人，对吧？我是那个“教堂”。我是那个将在你身上促成这种改变的人。所以我非常沉重地承担着这份责任。
And there are many patients over the course of 20 years that I have redirected, re-advised, recentered, and refused. Let's talk about those patients because I think regardless of, You know, if you're listening to this, regardless of whether you think plastic surgery is a good idea, you've had it done yourself, or you're one of those people who's like, I would never do that. I want to go through the psychological process of loving my body as it is. I think we can all kind of identify that there is a level where someone seeking out plastic surgery might be a little bit problematic. Can you tell me when you know, or instances where you've been like this person is probably not a good candidate for plastic surgery? Great question. So first and foremost, my overall philosophy is not that plastic surgery is good for everyone. As a matter of fact, absolutely, it's not good for everyone. My simple philosophy is that if you are the right candidate, and we've been sort of touching on what that is, and you do a good surgery and you find a good surgeon who collaborates with you, my experience for 20 plus years is that the
在过去20年的时间里，有很多患者被我重新引导、重新建议、重新居中并被我拒绝。让我们谈谈这些患者，因为我认为无论如何，你知道，如果你正在听这个节目，无论你认为整形手术是个好主意，还是你自己做过，或者你是那种说“我绝不会那样做”的人，我都想经历一下爱自己原本身体的心理过程。我想我们都能某种程度上认同，当某人寻求整形手术时，在某个层面可能有点问题。你能告诉我，当你知道时，或者在哪些情况下你会觉得这个人可能不是整形手术的好候选人？好问题。所以首先也是最重要的，我的整体哲学并不是整形手术对每个人都好。事实上，绝对不是对每个人都好。我的简单哲学是，如果你是合适的候选人，我们一直在探讨那是什么，并且你做了一个好的手术，找到了一个与你合作良好的外科医生，我20多年的经验是，
overwhelming majority of those patients do well. That doesn't mean everyone should be doing it. Conversely, there are absolutely people that shouldn't be doing it that are seeking it. And who are those people? And I tend to be a bit more transparent. If you follow me on social media, you listen to my podcast, everything and anything that comes out of my mouth is cautionary. I live and die. I'm sort of the Howard Stern meets Geraldo and the, you know,
绝大多数这样的患者都做得很好。这并不意味着每个人都应该这样做。相反，也绝对有人不应该这样做却在寻求它。这些人是谁？我往往更透明一点。如果你在社交媒体上关注我，你听我的podcast，我口中说出的任何事情都是警告性的。我靠这个生存。我有点像是霍华德·斯特恩（Howard Stern）遇见吉拉尔多（Geraldo）以及整形外科医生的调查记者。我就是那个每个人都不断发私信的人，比如：嘿，我应该做这个手术吗？这听起来很可疑。不。所以这些会是让我担忧的事情。第一点是当患者来到你面前，说他们有多么不喜欢某个东西，他们向你详细描述它是多么糟糕。而当你看着他们时，你根本看不出来。
report of investigator of plastic surgeons. I'm the guy that everyone keeps sending DMs to like, hey, should I do this procedure? This sounds fishy. No. So these are the things that would be a concern to me. Number one is when a patient comes into you and says how much they dislike something, they describe it to you in great detail of much how terrible it is. And when you look at them, you simply just don't see it.
就像我真心不知道你在说什么。一个完美的例子是今天刚来的一个女孩，她想要做鼻修复手术。最后我说，听着，我必须告诉你，我觉得你的鼻子看起来很好。它上面有一个小驼峰，有一点这个那个。但那些东西都很微不足道。总的来说，你看起来很好。我不会动它。所以红旗（警示信号）一号是：他们看到的，你没看到。对吧。如果我的儿子来找我，他四岁，说“爸爸，爸爸，你看到那个怪物了吗？”而我说，“我不知道你在说什么，巴拉巴拉。”你知道，我看不见你看见的。第二件亮红灯的事是，当他们表现得好像这个问题真的是生死攸关。
Like I genuinely don't know what you're talking about. A perfect example is a girl that came in just today who wanted a nose job, a revision nose job. And at the end, I said, listen, I have to tell you, I think your nose looks great. It has a little bump on it and a little this. But those things are like minor. By and large, you look good. I wouldn't touch it. So red flag number one is what they see, you don't see. Right. If my son comes to me, who's four years old and says, Papa, Papa, do you see the monster? And I'm like, I don't know what you're talking about, blah, blah. You know, I don't see what you see. Second thing that's a red flag is when they make it seem as though this issue is really the end-all be-all.
它会改变他们的生活。他们对某件事赋予了太多强调。你可以看出他们在心理上给这个项目附加了太多的价值，对吧？虽然我认为改变外表会创造一种自信感，然后这种自信感会渗透到你的人际关系中。我无法告诉你无数做了手术的人，因此极大地重燃了他们与所爱之人、男朋友、女朋友、丈夫、妻子的人际关系。但当你把它说得好像这会改变你的生活，就像你刚刚得到了，
It's going to change their lives. They apply too much emphasis on something. You can tell that psychologically they've attached too much value to this item, right? And while I think changing the way you look creates a sense of confidence, which then bleeds into your personal relationship. I cannot tell you the countless number of people who have had surgeries and as a result have massively kindled their interpersonal relationships with their loved ones, their boyfriends, their girlfriends, their husbands, their wives. But when you're making it sound like this is going to change your life, like you just got,
你知道的，我不知道，换了大脑移植。那这就令人担忧了。当患者在跟你谈论风险时他们完全不当回事，我说，你知道，我是那种“少承诺多兑现”的人。我非常倾向于，然后这可能会发生，然后那可能会发生。然后你可能会瘫痪，然后你可能会死。我的意思是，我非常末日论，因为我喜欢把事情往末日方向推，因为如果你经历了末日对话，你仍然愿意接受。
you know, I don't know, brain transplant. That's a concern. When patients don't track the risks when you talk to them, I say, you know, I'm very underpromise over-deliver kind. I'm very like, and then this can happen, and then this can happen. And then you could be paralyzed and then you could die. Like, I'm very much doomsday because I like to push the dooms because if you go through the doomsday conversation, you're still on board.
这意味着，你知道，你理解真正的风险。但当他们表现得好像无所谓、没有把风险听进去时，这让我担心他们无法坚持到底。当他们有任何类型的心理疾病，无论是边缘型人格障碍，他们非常紧张、无所谓。他们的情绪非常不稳定。他们一会儿哭一会儿又兴奋。他们一会儿生气一会儿又沮丧。
It means that, you know, you understand the real risks. But when they actually act like nothing, like they don't register it, it's a concern to me that they're not going to follow through. When they have any type of psychological condition, whether they have borderline disorder, they're very jittery, dismissive. They're very labile in their emotions. They're crying and then they're excited. They're angry and then they're depressed.
任何类型的剧烈情绪波动，我都不会做。当他们要求一些极端的事情，而我完全不认同——比如如果你身高5英尺2英寸（约157cm），体重125磅（约57kg），是个A罩杯，你带来了一张某位巨乳模特的照片，然后说“我想要这种巨大的胸部”。这就好像，根本不可能发生。所以记住，我不想跟一个术后结果不好的患者“结婚”。
Any type of mood swings, I won't do. And when they're asking for things that are extreme, that I just like, like if you're 5 foot two and you weigh 125 pounds and you're an A cup and you bring me a photo of some huge bar and you're like, I want these massive boobs. It's like, and there's no way that's going to happen. So remember, I don't want to be. entangled in a marriage with someone with a bad outcome.
所以，尽管我有责任阻止他们这样做，我也不想和你卷入其中，因为你最终会是一个不满意、不开心或没有好结果的患者。所以我花了很多时间确保我与合适的人“结婚”，因为一旦我在你身上动了手术，你就是我永远的责任，对吧？这不像我在商场里卖给你一个手袋。对。
So as much as it is my responsibility to prevent them from doing it, I don't want to get involved in this with you because you're ultimately going to be a patient who is going to be dissatisfied or unhappy or not have a good outcome. So I spend a lot of time trying to make sure that I marry the right people because once I operate on you, you're my forever responsibility, right? It's not like I sold you a bag, a handbag at the mall. Yeah.
然后你不开心。随便吧。然后你退货了。你会说，这个包太烂了。你会说，好吧，朋友，这是你的退款。祝你安好。这就好像我们永远绑在一起了。所以我非常谨慎，确保患者有现实且可行的期望。
And you're unhappy. Whatever. And you return it. You're like, this bag sucks. You're like, okay, here, buddy, here's your money back. Just be well. This is kind of like we're forever tied. So I am very cautionary about making sure that the patients have realistic and doable expectations.
而且他们在情绪上是稳定的，并且在当下显得很清醒。我想把重点放在你在这里说的第二点上，因为我觉得这很有趣，我觉得听众会希望我多谈谈这一点。那个说“这将是改变我生活的事情”的患者。为什么对这种人你不会动手术？你认为是因为背后有更深层的心理不安全感
And they're emotionally stable and seem to be present in that moment. I want to hone in on the second point you said here, because I think this is interesting, and I feel like the listeners will want me to talk about this a bit. The patient who is like, this is going to be the thing that changes my life. Why for them would you not operate on that kind of person? Do you think it's because there's a deeper psychological insecurity going on
或者他们与身体的关系更深，而手术无法解决，作为一名外科医生，这种患者有什么会让你感到害怕？所以听着，每个人都有不安全感，句号。所以这种观点——即有不安全感的人是不稳定的，你应该爱你的身体——又是无稽之谈。我不会让这些术语到处泛滥，至少在我的面前不行，因为这只会让那些真正做了手术并取得了惊人成果的人，对他们自己产生那种感觉。
or a deeper relationship with their body that like surgery can't fix, what about that kind of patient would maybe scare you as a, as a surgeon? So listen, every single person has insecurities, period. So this notion that, you know, the person who has insecurities is unstable and you should love your body is nonsense again. I'm not going to allow these terminologies to float around, or at least in my presence, because it just then makes people who actually had surgery and have an amazing outcome feel
每个人，包括我自己、我妻子、超人。维多利亚的秘密T台上的女孩都有不安全感。这是身为人类的一部分。关键在于要适度。这种不安全感要在合理范围内，不至于吞噬你。这种不安全感要在现实中说得通。我屁股上的这个酒窝让我有点不安全感。
that about themselves. Every single person, myself included, my wife, the supermarkets, the supermarkets, the superman. The girl walking down the runway at Victoria Secrets has insecurities. That's part of being human. It's about being in the center. It's about that insecurity being within reason where it doesn't consume you. It's about that insecurity making sense in reality. This dimple in my butt makes me a little insecure.
这并不意味着我再也不能在任何人面前赤身裸体了。你看到这两者之间的区别了吗？所以每一个来找我的人都在修复一种不安全感。我动过手术的每一个人，都不喜欢他们做手术的那个部位，无论是痣、胸部、鼻子，还是某个岛屿。那是不安全感。它令人担忧的地方在于，这种不安全感是如此宏大，以至于你把它描述得好像它改变了你整个人生。你有一个丑鼻子、大鼻子或者不适合你脸的鼻子，并没有改变你的生存本身。它并没有阻止你
It doesn't mean that I can never be naked in front of anyone again. Do you see how there's a difference between the two of those? So everyone that comes to me is fixing an insecurity. Every single human being that I've operated on doesn't like the thing. thing that they're operating on, whether it's the mole, whether it's the breast, whether it's the nose, it's the island. That's an insecurity. Where it becomes a concern is where that insecurity is so grand and it is so, you describe it as like, as it's altered your entire life. You having an ugly nose or a big nose or nose that doesn't fit your face is not altering your very existence. It's not preventing you
找工作。它没有阻止你找到一个好男朋友。它没有阻止你谈恋爱。它可能会让你感觉更快乐，你会更有自信，你会多拍几张照片，你在生活中会更有进取心。所以这关乎那种情绪的恰当性。所以这有点像
from getting a job. It's not preventing you from finding a good boyfriend. It's not preventing you from having a loving relationship. It might make you feel happier and you'll be a little more confident and you'll take a few more pictures and you'll be a little bit more aggressive in life. So it's about appropriateness of that emotion. So it's kind of like the difference
害怕狗和对狗稍微小心一点之间的区别，与害怕狗到看到街对面的狗就走到马路对面的区别。所以这是理智、合乎情理与不理性之间的区别。存在不理性的恐惧，也存在不理性的情绪。
between being scared of dogs and being a little careful around dogs and then being so scared of dogs that you see a dog across the street and you cross the street to the other side. So it's the difference between being reasonable and it's making sense and being irrational. There are irrational fears and there's irrational emotions.
当情绪与状况不相符时，这就是一个红旗信号，对吧？这是一个红旗信号。这有点像对某人进行“轰炸式示爱”（love bombing）。这就好比，你怎么能爱我？你才见我两个小时。不，我不是那个意思。所以当爱与我们关系的现实不平衡时。
And when the emotion is not congruent with the condition, it's a red flag, right? It's a red flag. And it's kind of like love bombing someone. It's like, how could you love me? You've only met me for two hours. No, I do you mean. So when the love doesn't balance out
当状况不相称时也是如此。现在，上帝保佑，上帝保佑你被烧伤了，你的脸被毁容了，你告诉我这毁了你的生活。好吧，那是一个该死的恰当的讨论。但那颗痣。对，不，我明白你的意思。
with the reality of our relationship. And it's the same thing when the condition, now, God forbid, God forbid you've been burned and your face has been mutilated and you're telling me it's destroyed your life. Well, that's a goddamn appropriate discussion. But the mole. Yeah, no, I see what you mean.
是的，因为状况与情绪相符。但当你来到我的办公室，你只是惊呆了、语塞了、不知所措了，我问，好吧，怎么了？你说，这颗痣，它只是，哪颗痣？这颗，就在这里。哦，好吧，它怎么了？嗯，它毁了我的生活，我就是不能……还有你的男朋友……你就会觉得，好吧，这只是一个问题。我（当然）用这个作为一个愚蠢的例子，但它可以是你的鼻子、你的胸部、任何东西，但你
Yeah, because the condition warrants the emotion. But when you come to my office and you're just flabbergasted and just for clamped and you're just beside yourself and I ask, okay, well, what's going on? You're like, this mole, it's just, which mole this one right here oh okay what about it well it just ruined my life and i just can't and my boy and you're like okay this is just this is a problem and i you know i obviously use that as a silly example but it can be your nose it can be your breast it can be anything but you
必须对它保持理性，这就是我所说的情绪稳定。事实是，外科医生做的咨询大多大约是15分钟，那是平均时间。我的咨询是一个小时。你认为我在这额外的45分钟里在做什么？我会说可能是在盘问那四件事，对吧，确保这个人情绪上准备好了。我百分之百在做的事就是深挖。我在深挖。我在与你对话。
have to be reasonable about it and that's what i mean about emotional stability and the truth is most consults that surgeons do is about 15 minutes that's the average my consults are one hour What do you think I'm doing for the additional 45 minutes? I would just say probably interrogating those four things, right, making sure that this person is emotionally ready. A hundred percent what I'm doing is digging. I'm digging. I'm having conversation with you.
我询问你的职业。你是做什么的？我可以在五分钟内检查完你并告诉你需要什么手术。我已经做这个20年了。我甚至不需要和你对话。只要把你的照片发给我。但咨询实际上是一场面试。这是你面试我。
I'm asking about your profession. What do you do? I can examine you in five minutes and tell you what surgery you need. I've been doing this for 20 years. I don't even need to have a conversation with you. Just send me your pictures. But the consult is actually an interview. It's for you to interview me.
我喜欢这个人。他看起来很酷。我不喜欢这个人。他看起来很傲慢。就是这样。然后是我面试你。你听起来不像是一个适合我照顾的好患者。我不太确定我能不能让你开心。
And I like this guy. He seems cool. I don't like this guy. He seems arrogant. It's that. And then for me to interview you, you don't sound like you're going to be a good patient for me to take care of. I'm not so sure I can make you happy.
对吧？我不知道我能不能让你开心。而我所做的事情的问题在于，它与所有其他专业完全不同，我产生的东西是主观的。是的。当你去切除胆囊时，有多少患者对切除胆囊不满意？切掉了就结束了。
Right? I'm not sure if I can make you happy. And the problem with what I do, that's totally different than every other specialty is what I produce is subjective. Yeah. When you go get your gallbladder removed, how many patients are unhappy about their gallbladder being removed? It's out the end.
除非有什么副作用。是的，确实如此。对吧，当然，如果你有并发症的话。但我的意思是，“切掉”是没有变化的。切掉了，或者没切掉。对吧？不，没错。但当你做鼻子时，我有四百万种排列组合。
Unless there's like a side effect. Yeah, genuinely. Right, of course, if you have a complication. But I'm saying is there's no variation of out. It's out or it's not out. Right? No, exactly. But when you do your nose, I have four million permutations.
虽然你和我可能会有很多对话，但世上谁能预测你的鼻子会变成什么样？你睡着了，你醒来，你变成了另一个人。你明白这种经历对我们两个来说有多么可怕吗？如果你讨厌它怎么办？而我觉得它看起来棒极了。这是主观的。你说，这是什么丑东西？我说，你什么意思？这是一件艺术品。太恶心了。我讨厌它。所以你大可打赌，我会花几个小时、额外的45分钟来深挖，以确保你和我能成为绝配。在我实践的这些年里，我做得相当不错。当然，也有少数人漏网了。
And while you and I may have a lot of conversation, who on earth can predict what your nose is going to look like? You go to sleep, you wake up, and you are a different. person. Do you understand how scary that experience is for both of us? What if you hate it? And I think it looks amazing. It's subjective. You say, what is this ugly thing? And I say, what do you mean? This is a work of art. It's disgusting. I hate it. So you better bet I'm going to spend hours, 45 extra minutes digging to make sure that you and I are going to be a good match. And in all the years I've been in practice, I've done a pretty good job. Of course, a few people slipped through the cracks.
是的，当然。但总的来说，我认为这对我很管用。随后的问题来了。这太迷人了。我觉得我学到了很多。当你有这样一个符合所有四个标准的患者时——好吧，我们假设是其中三个，我猜，我想你列出了四五个，我们假设是其中三四个。
Yeah, of course. But by and large, I think it's worked well for me. Follow up question here. This is so fascinating. I feel like I'm learning a lot. When you have one of those patients who fits all four criteria, well, let's say three of the, I guess, I think you gave four or five, let's say three of the four or five.
你对他们说什么？你会说，这里有个治疗师，我认为你应该去看看？你会说，这是我的一个朋友？你会说，给它六个月时间？比如，对于那些你觉得“这不会是个好主意”的患者，你的方案是什么？好问题。实际上，那可能是最具挑战性的咨询，
What do you say to them? Do you say, here's a therapist, I think you should go see? Do you say, here's a friend of mine? Do you say, give it six months? Like, what's your protocol for those patients who you're like, this isn't going to be a good idea for you? A great question. And actually, that is probably the most challenging consult,
走进一个房间。有人来找你。他们付了你咨询费。你内心里意识到这行不通。而你必须把他们从悬崖边劝下来，脚尖轻点着走出房间。所以这取决于情况。如果他们讲逻辑，我会花时间和精力，因为他们在我面前，我已经吸引了他们的注意力。坦白说，他们只会尊重整形外科医生的声音或理性，而不是他们妈妈的。
is to go into a room. Someone's come to see you. They paid you a fee. You internally realize this is not going to work. And you have to walk them off the ledge and tiptoe out of the room. So it depends. If they are logical, I will spend time and I will spend the energy because I have them and I have captivated their attention. And frankly, they only will respect the voice or the reason of a plastic surgeon, not their mom.
我妈妈也这么说，或者我的朋友们这么说。那些人不作数。我是个靠这个赚钱的专业人士。记住，我的动机是谋生。所以如果我告诉你这是一个坏主意，我就放弃了数千美元的收益。我得不到奥斯卡奖。我得不到任何奖杯。
My mom said the same thing or my friends. Those people don't count. I'm a professional who stands to make money from this. Remember, my incentive is to make a living. So if I'm telling you that this is a bad idea, I am foregoing thousands of dollars of benefit. I don't get an Academy Award. I don't get any trophies.
我只是在亏钱。所以如果他们在理性上是合乎逻辑的，我能感觉到我可以教育他们，那么我会花时间说，听着，让我给你看张照片。让我画一下这个。让我做这个。让我给你看那个。
I just lose money. So if they're rational in that they're logical, I can sense that I could educate them, then I will take the time to be like, listen, let me show you a photo. Let me draw this. Let me do this. Let me show you that.
这就是为什么那个。这就是那个。有时候我可以把他们拉回来，让他们看到这是一个坏主意。如果我发现根本无法说服他们，我永远不会不尊重患者，也永远不会让他们对自己所说的话感到难堪。我绝不会说，你知道吗，你疯了。我甚至不知道你在说什么。
This is why that. This is that. And occasionally I can walk them back to where they can see that this is a bad idea. If I find that there's just no getting around it, I'll never disrespect the patient or ever make them feel bad about what they're saying. I'll never say, you know what, you're crazy. I don't even know what you're talking about.
那绝对不会有什么好结果。所以通常情况下，如果我觉得我无法真正与他们建立联系并教育他们原因，我经常会告诉他们，你知道，你的情况非常复杂。说实话，我觉得我技术不够好。比如，我觉得我没有能力解决这个问题。换句话说，在技术方面，问题出在我身上，而不是你。因为到头来，他们会去别的地方做。我无法告诉你，其实，我无法告诉你，
That's just never going to go over well. So often, if I don't feel that I can really connect with them and educate them as to why, I'll often tell them that, you know, you have a very complicated situation. And to be honest, I don't think I'm skilled enough. Like, I don't think I'm good enough to fix this problem. In other words, I'm the issue here in terms of skill than you. Because at the end of the day, they're going to go and get it done. I cannot tell you, actually, I can't tell you.
我的诊所里有三分之一是修复手术。我的诊所里有三分之一的人是去了别的地方做、结果很糟糕的人。所以我很清楚，不幸的是，这种情况发生在我身上上千次了：我接待了患者，把他们从悬崖边劝下来，告诉他们这是个坏主意，然而他们从一扇门出去，又进了另一扇门。然后下一个医生说，不，不，不，那个人根本不知道你在说什么。他们做了手术，然后又回到这里问我怎么修复。我说，因为我有他们的病历，对吧？
One third of my practice is revisional. One third of my practice is someone that went somewhere, got it done, and it's a bad outcome. So I know, unfortunately, and I've happened to me a thousand times where I've seen patients, I've walked them off the ledge, I told them it's a bad idea, yet they go out one door and into another door. And the next guy says, no, no, no, that guy doesn't know what you're talking about. They do the surgery and then they come back here and ask me how to fix it. I'm like, because I have their notes, right?
我说，我四年前见过你。我没告诉过你不要做鼻子吗？我没告诉过你放过你的胸部吗？所以我知道很多人，他们只想听到他们想听的。我能做的引导也就是这样了。所以我可以说，处于那一类别的患者中，有50%我可以教育他们。我可以逐渐地、慢慢地把他们拉回来。然后另外一半，无论我对他们说什么，他们都会去别的地方。
I'm like, I saw you four years ago. Didn't I tell you not to do your nose? Didn't I tell you to leave your breasts alone? And so I know a lot of people are, they want to hear what they want to hear. And I can only do so much to guide them. So I would say 50% of the patients that are in that category, I can educate them. And I can gradually and slowly reel them back. And then the other half, you're going to go elsewhere no matter what I tell them.
他们就是一条直线非要做不可。你每天看社交媒体。看看有多少人在外表上变得如此怪异。很有可能他们在路上遇到了某个说“不”的人。而他们只是说：“去他的，我要去别的地方。我不在乎。”我的工作是不伤害他们。这是我的首要职责。
They're just have a beeline to get this done. And you look at social media every day. Look at how many people have gotten so far bizarre in terms of they look, the way they look. Chances are they met someone along the way that said no. And they just said, fuck it, I'm going to go somewhere else. I don't care. My job is to not harm them. That's my first duty.
我的首要职责是，你来找我，我不会参与。我不会开车送你去抢银行。我不是你的优步司机。我不会带你去你那个奇怪的目的地。这是个很好的比喻。这是一个非常好的比喻。我很喜欢。我们要进行最后一个简短的休息，
My first duty is you've come to me and I'm not going to participate. I'm not going to drive you to a bank robbery. I'm not your Uber driver. I'm not going to take you to your weird-ass destination. That's a good analogy. That's a very good analogy. I like that. We're going to take one more short break,
然后我想聊聊手术成瘾，也许还有你对二十多岁的人关于手术、关于其他事情的一些建议。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客“2%”中，我剖析了心理坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
and then I want to get to surgery addiction, and maybe some advice you have for people in their 20s, about surgery, about other things. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的。人。收听“2%”。也就是数字TWO percent，在IHeart
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result. of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart
Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在Look Back at It播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个时刻，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何在其中幸存下来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的对话，畅谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。
Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
需要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为快克。我很乐意在任何一天谈论快克，但只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看出有一条主线了。我们还把“艾滋病”摆上了台面。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table. now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。收听Look Back at It，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《用难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验。与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field. conversations with so many incredible guests.
我说的是。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
生活变成了关于赢和输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为地球上的人做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的。紧张关系，兄弟。绝对的。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different. tensions, bro. Absolutely.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。和我，基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《用难的方式学习》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真正的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭示了明显的矛盾。她在撒谎。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency. She's in her story.
这引发了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大队来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用来做什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格·莱斯比（Greg Lesbian）和迈克尔·纳拉尼尼（Michael Naranini）。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱之陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着季节的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻在
Greg Lesbian and Michael Naranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at
Greg Lesbian 和 Michael Naranini。我当时震惊了。我是 Stephanie Young。这里是“爱情陷阱”。Laura，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目继续，Laura Owens 终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻：
Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
随着劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉，美里科帕县的案件仍在继续。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事绝不会结束。在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一：永远不要惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。法则二：也永远不要惹她的朋友。
We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我们总是这么说，相信你的女性朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个多产的骗子。我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。于是她们决定自己采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我说，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我要做他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》。
I feel like we've been circling the drain on this one. I think it's come up like in a couple of times, which is surgery addiction. You said a third of your patients are there for revisions. Correct. People give you a laundry list of things that they want. We've all seen people who have been, I would genuinely say disfigured by plastic surgery. What's been your experience with that?
我觉得我们在这个问题上一直在原地打转。我觉得这个问题已经出现过好几次了，那就是整容成瘾。你说你的患者中有三分之一是为了修复手术来的。没错。人们会列出一长串他们想要做的项目。我们都见过那些可以说被整容毁容的人。你对此有什么经验？
And how do you, two questions. What's been your experience and this being a psychology podcast? What do you think the psychology behind that is? Okay. So they represent 0.000. 0.000% of patients. Let me reiterate. Body dysmorphia, which is the term for what you're describing, represents 0.000% of the patients out there. The overwhelming majority of patients are normal, regular folks like you and me, have an issue or two that they don't like, that they identify a surgeon,
还有，两个问题。你的经验是什么？既然这是一个心理学播客，你认为这背后的心理学是什么？好的。他们占患者总数的 0.000、0.000%。我重申一下。你所描述的这种身体变形障碍（Body Dysmorphia），占现有患者的 0.000%。绝大多数患者都是像你我一样的正常人，他们有一两个不满意的地方，然后去找外科医生，
and go get done. The fact that they have a bad outcome is not because they are crazy and they have body dysmorphia, it's because they pick the shitty surgeon. And the reason they picked the city shitty surgeon is because there are, for every one good surgeon, there's 14 charlatans running around acting like their experts. Now, to address your true quent question is, this body dysmorphia people, these people that look like the cat lady that look literally unrecognizable. Well, they're fascinating. That's why they occupy so much of the discussion when it comes to plastic surgery. I've done 100 podcasts. And every podcast are absolutely. to me about body dysmorphia because it's fascinating. Like it's a train wreck. We're all watching.
去把它做好。他们结果不好，并不是因为他们疯了或者有身体变形障碍，而是因为他们挑了个烂外科医生。他们之所以挑了个烂外科医生，是因为在这个行业里，每有一个好医生，就有 14 个江湖骗子到处假装自己是专家。现在，来回答你的真实问题，关于这些有身体变形障碍的人，这些看起来像“猫女”且面目全非的人。嗯，他们很迷人。这就是为什么在讨论整容手术时，他们占据了这么大比重的原因。我已经做过 100 期播客了。每一期播客都绝对会跟我聊到身体变形障碍，因为它太吸引人了。就像一场火车相撞事故。我们都在围观。
Like what the hell? Why does she look like that? And moreover, who did that to her? Yeah. So the issue is twofold. The issue is what's wrong with the person? And the second issue is who would have done that to that person? So body dysmorphia is a psychological condition. And it's a condition in which you see yourself as different than you really. are much like people who have anorexia and they are not well and they have some degree of paranoia and they have an underlying true psychological condition. So they need to be on medication, just like a schizophrenic needs to be on a medication, just like someone who hear voices need to be on a medication and seek psychological help. However, because often they're estranged, because often they're
就像：搞什么鬼？她怎么长成这样？而且更重要的是，是谁对她下得了手？是的。所以这个问题有两个方面。第一个问题是这个人出了什么问题？第二个问题是谁会对这个人做这种手术？所以，身体变形障碍是一种心理疾病。这是一种让你觉得自己和真实的自己不一样的情况，有点像患有厌食症的人，他们状况不佳，有一定程度的偏执，并且有潜在的真实心理疾病。因此，他们需要服药，就像精神分裂症患者需要服药一样，就像那些听到幻听的人需要服药并寻求心理帮助一样。然而，由于他们常常疏远他人，因为他们常常
isolated. Often they're just by themselves. Often they're at the end of their lifespan in terms of the money they've spent on themselves. They're usually not at a job with their husband and kids, not those people. I'm talking about body smorphia. People who walk around, you're like, whoa, there's no one who can intervene in those people. So that's not the issue. The issue is who the hell operated on this lady 17 times. Yeah. That's the sick part. The sick part isn't that they are. She had. Yeah, that she was sick.
孤立无援。他们常常独来独往。通常他们花在自己身上的钱已经到了人生的尽头。他们通常没有工作、没有丈夫和孩子，不是那种人。我说的是身体变形障碍。那些走来走去、让你觉得“哇”的人，没有人能干涉这些人。所以这不是问题所在。问题是到底是谁给这位女士做了 17 次手术。是的。这才是变态的地方。变态的不是他们，她曾有。是的，她生病了。
Somebody showed up. She went to somebody's office, having had three facelifts, looking literally like a stretched tambourine. And someone said, sure, I'll take your 20, 30, 40, 50 grand and do another facelift. That's the sick part because that's literally like child abuse as far as I'm concerned. It's like elderly abuse. This person is not well. So it happens.
居然有人接诊。她来到某个医生的办公室，已经做过三次面部拉皮手术，看起来简直就像一个被拉伸的手鼓。而竟然有人说：没问题，我收你两万、三万、四万、五万块钱，再给你做一次拉皮手术。这才是最变态的地方，因为在我看来，这简直就像虐待儿童。这就像虐待老人。这个人状况不佳。所以这种情况确实会发生。
I'm lucky in that it doesn't happen in my office. occasionally they'll get through the window. If you call my office and you say, I've had four facelifts and I'm thinking something's not right and I want a fifth, we just don't see you. I'm so sorry, you know, there's nothing we can do to help you. We're not going to engage the dialogue. There is no scenario in which, zero, where you need five facelifts before 50. That's one, like that's literally like one every five years.
我很幸运，这种事不会在我的诊所发生。偶尔会有人漏网。如果你打电话到我的诊所说：我做过四次面部拉皮手术，我觉得有点不对劲，我想做第五次。我们根本不会接待你。我很抱歉，你知道的，我们无能为力。我们不会开始对话。在任何情况下，绝无可能，你在 50 岁之前需要做五次面部拉皮手术。那是，这简直就是每五年做一次。
And it happens. There was a girl. There was a girl. What is the name? of that. And I don't know. She was like literally her six facelift. And she was like 50. So Faddi is more to thank the Lord. It's a very small minority. I think it's an addiction, right, as well, right? You have to treat this as something deeply psychological. A hundred, a hundred percent. It is the same exact area in the brain that leads to cocaine addiction, alcoholism, gambling,
这种事确实发生了。有个女孩。有个女孩。叫什么名字？我不知道。她当时差不多是第六次做面部拉皮手术。她才 50 岁左右。所以谢天谢地，身体变形障碍只占极少数。我觉得这也是一种成瘾，对吧？你必须把这当作一种深层的心理问题来对待。百分之百，百分之百。这正是大脑中导致可卡因成瘾、酗酒、赌博和
pornography. It is a impulse. I got two final questions for you. The first one is, here is your space to just address the biggest myth about plastic surgery that you want to address. And the second one is more specific to our audience. But I'll let you do that one first. What's the biggest myth that you want to address here about plastic surgery? So I think I have been blessed over 20 plus years to have been graced with so many amazing interpersonal experiences, thousands of letters and thank you notes and gifts and chocolates and and pictures and reviews from people whose lives I've improved.
色情成瘾的同一个区域。这是一种冲动。我有最后两个问题要问你。第一个问题是，这是你专门谈论你最想澄清的关于整容手术的最大迷思的机会。第二个问题更针对我们的听众。但我先让你回答第一个问题。关于整容手术，你最想澄清的最大迷思是什么？所以我觉得在过去的 20 多年里，我很幸运能够获得那么多美妙的人际交往体验，数不清的信件、感谢信、礼物、巧克力、照片，以及那些生活因我而改善的人们给我的评价。
So I don't like when plastic surgery gets a bad rap because inherently it's an incredible tool. That being said, my biggest quam and my biggest message is that tool is a very, very sharp knife. and if that knife is incorrectly, incorrectly handled, used on the wrong patient, done in the wrong way can create everlasting damage. And because of the things we discussed, more damage is being done than ever before, thereby tainting and ruining the beautiful possibilities that a good plastic surgical experience can bring. So what I say is people are now treating plastic surgery operating, going under anesthesia,
所以我不喜欢整容手术名声不好，因为它本质上是一个极其强大的工具。话虽如此，我最大的抱怨和最想传递的信息是：这个工具是一把非常非常锋利的刀，如果这把刀使用不当、操作失误、用错了患者、用错了方法，就会造成永远无法弥补的伤害。正因为我们讨论过的这些原因，现在造成的伤害比以往任何时候都要多，从而玷污和毁掉了优秀整容手术体验所能带来的美好可能。所以我想说的是，人们现在对待整容手术、动手术、全身麻醉，
like it's literally going and getting extensions. They have lost their reverence for it. They have lost their fear of it. They have lost their, you know, if you were going to do something super significant in your life, you would do a tremendous amount of analysis before. Plastic surgery is no longer in that category. It's like a whimsical decision. And that is my biggest concern for young adults.
就像去接发一样随便。他们对它失去了敬畏之心。他们失去了对它的恐惧。他们失去了……你知道的，如果你要在生活中做一件非常重大的事情，你会在此之前进行大量的分析。整容手术不再属于这一类了。它就像是一个异想天开的决定。这就是我最担心年轻人的地方。
It's something you feel like you want. And the biggest issue is at 20, you can't afford it. So what I see more than ever is that when you're $25,000 is a lot of money at 20. And as a result, when someone good is 10 grand and someone mediocre is $5,000, is five grand, you have to have it. I have to have this now. And you forego what you would normally have done in any other scenario. And you say, how bad could it be? Because it's getting extensions. And so a lot of the revisions I do are in people who had surgery as young adults. And at that time, aside from the fact that their wisdom hadn't settled in, there's a reason why 20 year old people do
这是你觉得自己想要的东西。而最大的问题在于，你在 20 岁的时候根本负担不起。所以现在我看到更多的情况是，当你 20 岁时，2.5 万美元是一大笔钱。因此，当一个优秀的医生收 1 万美元，而一个平庸的医生收 5,000 美元时，你就会觉得你必须马上拥有它。我必须现在就做这个。于是你放弃了在任何其他情况下本会做出的正常考量。你会说：能有多糟呢？反正就跟接发一样。因此，我做的许多修复手术，都是针对那些在年轻时做过手术的人。当时，除了他们的阅历还不够成熟之外，20 岁的人会做
stupid shit and 60-year-old people are like, God, when I was 20, what the thing. Because that's when you are in the military. That's when you get into fights. That's when you go to war. That's when you protest. That's when you are at a certain place in your life that you're conquering things. You don't make always the best judgment. And the problem is that you don't have the finances to do what's better.
一些蠢事，而 60 岁的人会说：天哪，我 20 岁时怎么会做那种事，这是有原因的。因为那就是你当兵的年纪。那是你跟人打架的年纪。那是你上战场年纪。那是你参加抗议的年纪。那是你人生中某个正在征服一切的阶段。你的判断力并不总是最好的。而问题在于，你没有资金去做更好的选择。
So my biggest advice is save your money. So if you can't afford the person that you did homework on, that's 10 grand, Don't kid yourself that the four grand, three grand guy is just as good or I'll go to, I don't know, the Bahamas or Turkey or Greece. I'm saying be wise, put your mature thinking cap on and just treat it with the reverence that it deserves. And if you do that, then I hope for you that you will be a part of what I experience in my practice, which is amazing, transformative experiences. And that's what it should be. 99% of plastic surgery should be amazing. Like, wow, this was fucking great.
所以我最好的建议是：存钱。如果你负担不起你做过功课的那位收费 1 万美元的医生，不要自欺欺人地认为那个收 4 千、3 千美元的医生也一样好，或者我要去什么巴哈马、土耳其或希腊。我的意思是，要聪明点，拿出你成熟的头脑，以它应有的敬畏之心去对待这件事。如果你这样做了，那么我希望你会成为我诊所里所经历的那部分人——那些拥有美妙、蜕变般体验的人。这才是它应有的样子。99% 的整容手术都应该是极好的。就像：哇，这太棒了。
I'm so happy I did this. And there's just a lot of bad decisions being made. Yeah, that's great advice. Now that we have you in the advice-giving mood, this is the question that we ask everybody, which is a piece of advice you would have for yourself in your 20s or people in their 20s now that has nothing to do with what we talked about today. So I think for me personally, one of the things that I probably over did that I wish I didn't
我太高兴我做了这个。只是现在有太多糟糕的决定了。是的，这真是个绝佳的建议。既然你现在很乐于给出建议，这也是我们问每个人的一个问题：对于 20 岁的自己，或者现在正处于 20 多岁的人，你有什么建议是与我们今天讨论的内容无关的？我想对我个人而言，我可能过度做了一件事，我希望我当初没有这么做，那就是
is I spent too much of my young adult worrying about getting where I needed to go in life. So there are two major paths in life, those that really plan and those that don't plan enough. And generally the conversation is, hey, you got to have a plan, kid. Like you can't just let the universe take you where it goes. You're never going to get there. And that's actually quite true. But because of my personality, I think I over planned and over worried and over stressed about my destination. And so I got to where I got in life, which I'm so grateful I got married and I had kids a little bit late and I have a wonderful practice.
我花在年轻时过度焦虑如何达到人生目标的精力太多了。所以人生有两条主要道路，那些真正做规划的人和那些规划不够的人。通常人们会说：嘿，孩子，你得有个计划。你不能任由命运把你带到任何地方。你永远到不了终点。这其实挺对的。但由于我的性格，我觉得我对终点站进行了过度规划、过度担忧和过度压力。所以我走到了我今天在人生中所在的位置，我很感激自己结婚了，稍微晚一点有了孩子，我有一家很棒的诊所。
Everything about my life is where I always imagined it to be. But I think I worried too much about getting here. And it took a little bit of the fun out. out of it. I was all too worried about making it to my end destination and not enough time, not smelling the rosars or watching the view, but relaxing a bit. And so for the type A people who are out there, you can probably release the reins a bit. And as long as you're headed in the right direction, you'll probably get to your end destination without having to knuckle grip it all the way there. I love that advice. And you know what?
我生活中的一切都和当年想象的一样。但我认为我太担心如何到达这里了。这剥夺了一些应有的乐趣。我过于担心能否到达最终目的地，而没有花足够的时间去闻闻玫瑰的芬芳、看看风景，也没有好好放松一下。所以对于那些 A 型人格的人，你们大概可以稍微松一松缰绳。只要你们朝着正确的方向前进，你们很可能就能到达最终目的地，而不必一路死死抓着不放。我太喜欢这个建议了。你知道吗？
It's very pertinent because that is the question I get. The theme of questions I get all the time, which is like, how do I know that I'm on the right path? Like, how do I know where I'm going? So I like what you said. Like the destination will be there. You can take a bit of time. Yeah. I mean, you've got to have, first of all, if you don't, if you're not on a path, you will make it anywhere.
这非常贴切，因为这就是我经常收到的问题。我一直收到的问题都有一个共同的主题，那就是：我怎么知道我走的是正确的路？我怎么知道我要去哪里？所以我喜欢你刚才说的。终点自然会在那里。你可以花点时间。是的。我的意思是，首先，如果你不，如果你没有走在一条路上，你无论如何都能走到某个地方。
So you don't know that you're on the right path, but you need to be on a path. That's first of all. You have to, you have to be in the best thing. You have to be in the game, and that path has to be one that's worthy of traveling, even if it ends up not being the one. So, A, you can't not be on a path and B, pick a path that's worthy of traveling, and don't worry about it if it's the path. If you are on a path and it's a path worthy traveling, the path will present itself. I want to say thank you so much for coming on the podcast. Yes. Can I have a moment to plug my podcast?
所以你并不知道自己是否走在正确的路上，但你必须走在某条路上。这是第一点。你必须，你必须参与其中，而且那条路必须是一条值得走的路，即使到头来它可能不是那条最终的路。所以，第一，你不能不走在路上；第二，选择一条值得走的路，如果它不一定是那条终极之路，也不要为此担忧。如果你走在路上，而且这是一条值得走的路，那条路自然会向你展现。我想非常感谢你来到这个播客。是的。我能花点时间宣传一下我的播客吗？
Yeah, absolutely. I think that if people enjoy this dialogue, which I hope they did, meaning if you have any interest in cosmetic surgery, which most people find kind of curious or fascinating or whatever, I have an amazing podcast called Plastic Surgery Unsex, which as from this podcast, you can get a gauge of how I communicate information. And it really covers everything in plastic surgery, from minor things to major things, to trends, to disasters, catastrophes, to patients, to pastrophies, to patients, to patients. their journeys to experts to et cetera. It's called plastic surgery uncensored. You find it all over to play Spotify, Apple, whatever, whatever. It will be in the description as well. Yeah. And I think that for anybody who wants more of this kind of stuff,
当然可以。我觉得如果人们喜欢这种对话，我希望他们喜欢的话，也就是说，如果你对整容手术有任何兴趣，大多数人会觉得这有点好奇或着迷什么的，我有一个很棒的播客叫《Plastic Surgery Uncensored》（整容手术大解密），从这期播客中，你可以了解我沟通信息的方式。它确实涵盖了整容手术的一切，从微整形到大手术，从流行趋势、灾难、惨剧到患者、患者，他们的心路历程、专家等等。它叫《Plastic Surgery Uncensored》。你在 Spotify、Apple 等等各种平台上都能找到它。它也会出现在节目简介里。是的。我想对于任何想要了解更多这类内容的人来说，
you can kind of dig in and do a little deep dive there. And then if they want to follow me or anything, it can always come on to our Instagram and peruse at Dr. Roddy Raban, which is DR, R-A-D-Y-H-B-A-N. So we'd love to have some of your 20s. My dream is to get a hold of all the 20s, 20 year old before they do shitty mistakes. That's my goal is to get ahead of it, not to fix it afterwards. So good on you for having a podcast that is specifically targeting young adults because often the choices we make in young adulthood are the ones that forever change our lives.
你都可以深入挖掘并做一点深度探讨。然后，如果他们想关注我或了解什么，随时可以来我们的 Instagram 浏览 @Dr.RoddyRaban，也就是 DR, R-A-D-Y-H-B-A-N。我们很希望能吸引一些 20 多岁的年轻人。我的梦想是在所有 20 多岁的人犯下愚蠢的错误之前抓住他们。我的目标是防患于未然，而不是事后去修复。所以，很高兴你有一个专门针对年轻人的播客，因为我们在青年时期做出的选择往往是那些永远改变我们一生的选择。
And if we can alter them early enough, maybe the trajectory will be better. I appreciate it. Well, it was such a pleasure to have you on board. If you enjoyed this episode, give us a five-star review. Share it with a friend and follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to, you know, give any feedback, if you have any further questions or thoughts about this episode or any other episodes, if you want us to expand on anything we talked about, or if you just want to see behind the scenes, we'd love to have you over there. But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon.
如果我们能足够早地改变它们，也许人生轨迹会变得更好。我很感激。很高兴你能来做客。如果你喜欢这一集，请给我们五星好评。分享给朋友，并在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology Podcast。如果你想提供任何反馈，或者对本节目或其他节目有任何进一步的问题或想法，如果你想让我们深入探讨我们讨论过的任何内容，或者如果你只是想看看幕后花絮，我们非常欢迎你加入我们。但直到下一次，保重，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or... wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这就是当电梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇妙的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你将破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是由 TWO% 呈献的节目。
On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
在《Look Back at it》播客中。对 1979 年来说，那对我是一个重大时刻。84 年对我来说也很重大。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每期节目中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同仁喜剧作家以及最喜爱的作家一起。
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway
就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代一样。84 年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听的是由
with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability
你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·甘斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都根本不安全进行的诚实对话，但你们是在与一位知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士进行这些对话。多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，
that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern.
并不意味着你非得这么做。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023 年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。互联网侦探们动用了大量人力，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target.
在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个多产的骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我要做他最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust. your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts,
他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是这么说，相信你的女性朋友。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust me, babe》。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。